[موسيقى]
توم ستوكر قام بالكثير من الرحلات الجوية
الأسبوع الماضي، يا إلهي، من الصعب أن
أتذكر كل شيء هونولولو لندن سان
فرانسيسكو كنت في شيكاغو كنت في
سنغافورة تايلاند هذا النظام يستمر 10
أيام في عام 1990 اشترى تذكرة
بخمسمائة وعشرة أيام  ألف دولار
منحه هو ورفيقه تذاكر غير محدودة من
الدرجة الأولى لشركة يونايتد إيرلاينز مدى
الحياة في الواقع خلال تلك السنوات الأولى،
كان لدي خوف من الطيران،
ولم يعد التوقف مؤقتًا متاحًا بعد الآن ولكن
بأموال اليوم سيكلف أكثر من
مليون دولار ليس خلال مليون عام
في  في ذلك الوقت، فكرت في أنني يمكن أن
أكون المسافر الدائم رقم واحد في العالم حيث
شاركت الآن في أكثر من
12000 رحلة جوية وحلقت أكثر من 23 مليون
ميل، وهو يعتبر
المسافر الأكثر تكرارًا في العالم، كما تعلم أن الناس يقولون كيف
يمكنك القيام بذلك، فقلت حسنًا  أنا مستلقي على
السرير، أشرب الشمبانيا وأشاهد
فيلمًا، ولا أبحث عن الكثير من
الشفقة هنا وعلى طول الطريق كان
قادرًا على التوصل إلى بعض الطرق للتعامل
مع تأخير الرحلة المخيف الذي لا مفر منه
أولاً  وقبل كل شيء،
اخرج من سريرك مبكرًا لأن
أفضل وقت للطيران
هو الوقت الذي يمكن الاعتماد عليه أول شيء في الصباح إذا كان
هناك عطل ميكانيكي أو تأخير على طول
الطريق، فمعظم الرحلات الجوية التي تم تأجيلها
أو إلغاؤها تكون في وقت لاحق من اليوم عندما
تكون  لقد تأخرت أو ألغيت في
الساعة الرابعة بعد الظهر، لا تأتي
باكيًا إلي، لقد أخبرتك بذلك ثم عليك
الحصول على تطبيق الخطوط الجوية، لقد
أبلغوني بإلغاء رحلتك، لقد
قمنا بإعادة الحجز على هذه الشريحة بالفعل
الآن إذا لم يكن الأمر كذلك  الرحلة التي أردتها
يمكنك حرفيًا في منتصف
الجو فوق جنوب المحيط الهادئ بعد خمس ساعات
من الهبوط، هذه هي الرحلة التي أريد
أن أكون عليها الآن، هذا هو المقعد الذي أريده،
أنت قادر على الحصول على كل هذا بعيدًا
ورقم ثلاثة  كن استباقيًا في أي مكان
توجد فيه مدن ثانوية، لذا إذا تم
إلغاء رحلتك إلى شيكاغو، فابحث في
الرحلات الجوية إلى ميلووكي أو المدن القريبة من
شيكاغو التي يسهل الوصول إليها بالسيارة لأنه إذا تم
إلغاء معركتك، فستكون الأمور على ما يرام، فما عليك سوى الحصول على
الرحلة التالية جيدًا في المرحلتين التاليتين
يمكن أن تكون الرحلات الثلاث التالية
ممتلئة تمامًا، وعندما تكون تلك
المقاعد القليلة الفارغة، عادةً ما يتم إعطاؤها
لركاب الدرجة الأولى الذين كانوا
على متن رحلة خارجية سابقة